okay we're gonna get started i'm shannon
McWeeny i'm the division head for
bioinformatics and computational biology
indie mice dr. Hirsh who normally does
the introductions he's away on travel so
I have the honor today we're here for a
proposal defense in which the students
are going to be presenting the ideas for
their thesis brandon Keibler who's to my
left is one of our masters students in
buy with my conditional biology he had
done his bachelor's degree in
bioinformatics at Pacific University
he's a second year student and he'll be
talking today about work on semantic
workflows for neuro imaging he's also
involved in another collaboration
besides his thesis which is on trans
possible elements if you're online at
home or a river and want to tweet
questions will be monitoring Twitter and
the conf we are seeing two-dimensional
representations of the brain as you see
in the background of this image just
keep in mind that that's usually just
one single slice one single view of a
much larger three-dimensional model and
if I do ever use return voxel in this
presentation just know that that's
essentially a pixel so how do I give
these images mainly this is done through
magnetic resonance imaging because this
allows us to get there high-quality
images of the brain in a very minimally
invasive way basically the way that this
works is subject is placed inside of MRI
machine or in our case perhaps just
their head and then large magnet creates
strong
that it feel around the subject
basically this is going to leverage the
fact that our bodies are made mostly of
water so this magnetic field that's
created causes the protons in the
hydrogen atoms of the water molecules to
all line up and orient themselves in the
same direction from there is
radiofrequency coil I'm into a
radiofrequency that excites the protons
and then it's turned off and that's
those protons return to equilibrium they
release around radio signals and this is
most commonly used clinically to detect
irregularities in a subjects brain you
can see here in this example it's being
used to identify the presence of brain
tumor expands over the course of time
this is done just using structural
images done by the standard MRI I can
also be used to incorporate functional
MRI called just MRI data to show
activity in the brain in this example
here they're looking tax a child who's
currently undergoing an epileptic
seizure oh where is the warm colors
indicate portions of the brain that are
more active that's compared to the
resting state where's the cooler and so
this has basically done by using
something called old imaging which
stands for blood oxygen level dependent
and the basic concept here is that one
as a part of the brain becomes more
active the body responds by increasing
the blood flow that part of the brain
which correlates then to a higher
concentrations of oxygenated blood in
that area and basically there's some
differences in a magnetic susceptibility
oxygenated and deoxygenated blood and
the MRI machine is able to pick up on
that so essentially the way an image
like this and seizure example how that
image is created first take structural
image of the brain which usually takes
about of time somewhere around our to
take that high-resolution image and then
the functional MRI pictures which are
only interested in the brain a
particular point in time
taken so these are much faster than half
shots they can result in a much lower
resolution image well then basically you
take the functional MRI image at one
point the resting state in compared to
the functional MRI image Wow undergoing
in this case the seizure and functional
images are then superimposed on top of
the structural image of the brain so you
can actually see where that activity are
taking place another way that's to be
used so in this case we are looking at
how the activity of different parts of
the brain correlate with each other was
essentially done by taking a time series
of these functional MRI images and you
look at one particular point of the
image and see how that how that signal
changes over time which results in this
graph mapping out the brain activity
pattern another part of the brain
similar growth and compare them to to
see how well they correlate so in this
example here we're looking at
individuals with and without ADHD and
this is looking how all all of these
different parts of the bringing how they
correlate with another
called the nucleus accumbens just right
about here between orange in the blue
and so areas of the warm color that's
where when the activity of the nucleus
accumbens increases they they also
increase their activity patterns are
correlated with each other the cooler
colors indicate areas where the activity
of those two regions are inversely so
probably the most highest profile
example this kind of work is the human
connectome project Lawrence Wofford a
cooperative effort to not see the human
brain and so it basically established a
foundation of the functional anatomy of
the brain and what variation of that is
this population one of the things to
come out of this is the minimal
processing pipelines so this is
essentially what they've established the
standardizing method for taking the raw
MRI images and and processing them into
that I'm not going to get into ideas
they're structural images and prepare
them which in and of itself is composed
of three separate pipelines working one
after the other and then from there that
can incorporate functional data which in
itself this process or they can bring in
also a pipeline bringing
diffusion-weighted images which is to
basically we're gonna just be looking at
the very first step which is called the
pre freesurfer pipeline named thus
simply because it comprises all of the
processing steps that take place before
the next pipeline which uses the freeze
for software package this is a very very
simplified map of what's going on here
there's a lot of steps that I'm not
showing but basically this pipeline is
focused on one is correcting the images
for various levels of distortion three
sources of distortion as well as a bias
field which I'll talk about more
basically a signal corruption that comes
up
damaging and the second goal is to align
the individuals brain to reference brain
so we start off with our brain images
here we're showing that there's there's
basically two versions of Lists the team
won waited a t2-weighted image which are
two separate images that are taken
ideally around the same time that are
just taking them using different
settings on the MRI machine kind of
think ibly is is taking a picture with
or without the flash on and the
t1-weighted image is kind of what is
more focused on the t2-weighted image
comes into play because we found that
it's basically helps inform some of the
processing algorithms basically the
different levels of contrast between the
different parts of the brain and these
two images that information can be used
to help give you some more accurate
results from different processes such as
separating out the white matter and the
gray matter from the brain the
t2-weighted image like I said the
importance of this has kind of been
recognized a little bit more recently
there's certain situations for that
might not be available
such as
you're looking at data from their study
myopic present ideally both of these
then when you're getting out of it is
basically two different images the
original brain on the far left there
which is corrected for process brain
image for a particular individual and
then a separate version of that which is
aligned to a reference brain template a
process called registration which I'll
go into more detail moment but basically
the original individuals brain
everyone's brain has unique size and
shape to it
and so this that's reflected in that
brain image and the registered bringing
is basically the same brain made
informed for the size and shape of the
reference template and that would be the
appropriate version to use when doing
project comparisons so depending on what
you're doing
downstream you know sorry the the
original brain this is this is the
individuals brain you know what's called
their native space this is the their
natural shape of their brain and then
the reference is basically just a
standardized brain shape that the
original brain is then transformed to
conform to that same shape so that if
you're looking at two separate
individuals this part of the brain is
going to be in the same place
the first time distortion does its
pipeline correct for its radiant
Distortion
these are distortions that arise to the
imperfections magnetic field gradient
basically the yellow crosshairs here are
is the ISO sender for the scans being
taken and then as you can see the
further away you get from that the
stronger
basically the further away you get its
the stronger effect of these gradient
distortions are and you can see in this
example before their Corrections done
the original image seen those obviously
in the neck where it's kind of squished
together whereas after you the
correction the end of the neck looks
more accurate to the actual anatomy so
this is the stuff that's recommended but
somewhat considered optional it kind of
depends on the MRI machine that's used
to acquire the images some of them are
more susceptible to this type of
distortion than others so in a lot of
cases this can actually give it another
type of distortion which is
comparatively minor is called readout
distortion this basically arises from
varying magnetic susceptibility of
different tissues and so this is correct
before by using what's called a field
map which is something that's acquired
beef ideally immediately before frying
requiring the structural images of the
brain and there's different ways you can
create a red knob reference map but
basically it's going to be a file that
it's gonna be a file that basically just
defined where this rehab distortion is
occurring in the image as you can see
here this is an example where two images
are taken I'm using different readouts
in direction but basically these two
images are taken before actually
acquiring the structural image and you
can see that there's slight differences
probably most noticeable right here
where the picture is a little bit
different so basically these two would
be used together and then where these
differences occur it's going to inform
in the field map where this readout
distortion is occurring and that can
then be used to correct for that our
structural damages yeah like I said
there are a couple of different ways you
can create a field map which again might
not always during under certain
circumstances might not be available and
if that's the case you likely have to
skip just distortion correction which
can be okay depending on the sensitivity
analysis you're doing again bias field
is not extortion but it's basically a
gradual signal gain in the image that's
caused by the variations and that in the
magnetic field as opposed to the actual
and this is where that t1 and t2
weighted images come into play
essentially you can combine the t1 and
t2 weighted images effectively cancel
each other out and then what signal is
left over is going to be resulting from
that high school
subtract that someday the structural
manages to remove corruption and like I
mentioned a bit earlier the teaching
under certain circumstances that
t2-weighted image is not always
available in which case there are
alternative methods to correct for this
to estimate that bias field that don't
rely on the t2-weighted image used in
those cases and then the final step is
registration which I mentioned a bit
already basically it's a nonlinear
transformation to transform the
individuals brain to conform with the
reference brain template and get you
that standardized brain shape so
and this is another place where the
reference map that you're using that's
going to be informed by what kind of
study you're doing what kind of subjects
you're working with normally we would
just use the standard of don't human
brain reference if you're working with
different animals to want to use the
reference that's appropriate for that
species example but basically this
pipeline is provided as a shell script
they're a group of shell scripts that
are designed to be run from the command
line and generally comes out looking
some a lot of things you can do to make
this one more manageable but if you were
to run just the pre freesurfer pipeline
which again is just the very first step
in this process running straight through
can be typing in something along these
lines and there are even even more
parameters here that I'm not showing and
you know the situation exactly what
you're doing and how you got your data
kind of determines what parameters you
have to use and some of these and their
other circumstances wouldn't even come
up I want to conclude here but basically
what I want to show is that this is kind
of a mess it's hard to kind of keep
track of what's going on and certainly
vulnerable to typos and such so this is
kind of becomes a concern as far as
reproducibility reproducibility being
kind of a hot topic in science at the
moment essentially some studies have
been done to show that when they try to
reproduce
end up getting different results but
some estimates but the amount of
preclinical research that's simply not
reproducible I think somewhere around 50
percent cancer being especially come to
this with 89% of it reduce of both and
that kind of things the question if we
are not able to reproduce their studies
than how much can we really rely and
their findings so this kind of translate
into a lot of time and a lot of money
being spent on studies that we can't
really trust and so one way this has
tried people have tried to address this
as far as running pipeline data
processing goes to use workflow
management systems which essentially
attempt to make this process a lot more
accessible and a lot more user friendly
by doing things such as providing a few
interface and providing visual
representations of the workflow and so
one example which is used pretty heavily
in the galaxy and how access to a large
library of tools commonly used in
genomics without having to install any
of the software on their own system and
then of course this allows you to
arrange those different tools select
them and fight them together you process
your data another example that's much
more focused on neuro
is called lani pipeline some stand-alone
software but again this comes with a pre
created library of processing tools that
are used commonly in neuroimaging allows
you again to make your big together
gonna work close and even visualized as
a process through the various steps and
so this is just a couple of them there
are tons and tons for full mattress it's
out there they're all have their own
benefits but they all have their own
limitations well
so using these workflows effectively
still requires a certain level of
knowledge about the workflow from the
user specifically regarding what
algorithms are being used the different
parameters that are involved in these
algorithms and what would be the
appropriate values for those as well as
any assumptions that they have about the
data that you're inputting the process
which can go a lot farther than just you
know whether it's the right file type
additionally any for putting in multiple
input files and there's often
assumptions about how those two inputs
are related in any interdependencies
that they might have between each other
which often aren't explicitly shown to
the user so one thing that's kind of
come out to try to address some of these
limitations are our semantic workflows
and basically why they stand out from
other workflows is that they encode a
certain level of knowledge about a
workflow into the workflow itself which
it does by implement
or called semantic constraints basically
semantic constraints are there to
provide an extra layer of error checking
and rule enforcement help a user operate
a workflow add those intended so this
kind of some examples of what these
semantic constraints look like a
precursor for pipeline the very first
step is the gradient distortion
correction which again is case is
optional but it's highly recommended for
certain MRI machines that are very
susceptible to the distortion so
information to metadata about the files
including who was this brain belongs to
when when the image is acquired and one
machine was used to support it and it
can pick out whether or not that great
and distortion correction is especially
necessary and in this case recommend
that it be used where it might otherwise
just be skipped
another example in genomics when you're
doing patient variant analysis you
basically have a final showing the DNA
sequences for an individual and you want
to compare that to a database of known
DNA variants to see which of those
variants your patient has both of these
files were created by aligning Janak
reads to genome assembly
reference genome from human genome of
which there are several versions and if
those if those two files were made using
different genomic assemblies then
suddenly the genomic location referenced
in this bottle aren't going to correlate
such genomic locations reference in this
file and all the things going to fall
apart in this case
Oana genetic constraints identify this
issue and prevent this workflow from
being run I'm so kind of in a more broad
more broadly speaking some of the
capabilities of semantic constraints
ensure compatibility like we saw with
the previous example that allow us to
restrict selectable input so once a user
selects one input file when they go to
select the next one it's only going to
show it can also recommend inputs and
parameters to the user based off
information and fitting from from the
inputs I've already been selected it can
also be used to dynamically assigned
metadata to your files so they
automatically have made of data that
describes what kind of processing steps
were used it can also be used for some
automatic processing path selection
you've got two different algorithms that
are used for the same same process or
using different situations if there's
any any way that you can encode those
situations into the amplifier then smack
constraints can be used to automatically
recommend or select which so a workflow
management system that allows the use of
these semantic constraints and the one
that I'll be using in my project is
called means stands for a workload
instance generation selection somewhat
similar to galaxy in that it's a
web-based tool but you can access from
anywhere basically you can select your
workflows that you want to run
together with input files you want to
through it see the representation of how
the data is gonna be processed and run
it one other thing this allows us to do
is you can basically define these steps
or what are called modules and wings to
carry out certain you know an individual
algorithm processing algorithm or even a
series of algorithms basically providing
a trim layer layer of abstraction so the
user doesn't need to necessarily concern
themselves with all than anybody details
and just focus on the general steps
being used
so given this I hypothesized that the
operation of a semantic workflow for
medical image processing in the Hamptons
usability test that using these panes
first the development of a semantic
workflow to process brain MRI images and
then to evaluate usability so the first
step is obviously to meet it I'll be
implementing the semantic version of the
pre freesurfer pipeline in wings and
while doing so I'll be being sure to
implement some it constrains protect
from needs or possible sources of user
error and kind of guide the user through
the handling the processing pipeline and
ideally do through this became enhanced
reproducibility as well so some of the
semantic constraints that plan on
implementing first whether or not the
gradient distortion correction
necessary can be determined by looking
at what type of my machine is used from
data acquisition and make
recommendations as to whether or not
that steps necessary at all the use
without distortion correction in order
to do this we're going to need a field
map that defines the readout distortion
so that's not available that's one step
that we need to skip alternative
alternative bias field correction
handling like I said we often don't have
that t2-weighted image available and in
which case you can recommend different
processing algorithms handle this at
that border if necessary skip it all
together and also the compatibility of
the reference frame map and the subject
data obviously if we're if we're looking
at non-human primate we're gonna want to
use a reference bring them out that's
appropriate for that and then the second
step is to evaluate the usability of our
semantics workflow doing some user
testing so we plan to recruit applied
experienced users have them use our work
using four different sample data sets
that we've put together to highlight the
different abilities different benefits
semantics and then once we've done all
that they'll report on their experience
using a short survey so the four data
sets that we plan on having people use
basically the first one is just a normal
very straightforward data set I would
allow you there's too many custom
we can kind of illustrate how the
different parameters can be restricted
or recommended second one is missing
data again an example would be if we
don't have a t2-weighted image workflow
and then recommend alternate method to
do the vise field correction the third
data set just be ultimate handling yeah
potentially you know data said young
child or in which case the workflow can
recommend use last one being miss label
inputs so in a situation where if you
have t1 and t2 weighted image and
through some previous error one of the
two its mislabeled as its belonging to
an individual we can use semantic
constraints to try to look at the
metadata of those files whether it's the
day that the images were taken and the
age of the subject and try to catch
these inconsistencies and then provide a
warning to the user to the text a
problem so take a quick usability survey
that we based on an established survey
called the system usability scale which
is comprised of 10 to not questions
defense statements that the user will
then indicate whether they agree or
disagree with it and then the responses
from those can be used to calculate the
overall score
the general idea of how usable the
system was and then addition to that
we'll also be including some free
response questions for specific feedback
as well as facilitating everything yeah
he's asking so since these images are
Green images are three-dimensional
images saying if they're essentially a
stack of two-dimensional images twirling
to all the different slices of the brain
is asking if there's anything in between
those slices that we want to keep track
of
yeah
and it will be
well you have the original image so
necessarily Deeley need to convert back
the original image is saved but then
also produces files that describe what
transformations were taken to go from
the original brain to the registered one
so imagine that we went backwards we
were pushing the reference frame but
excessively you have to interpolate
okay there would be a file that
describes you know transformation so you
can then use that correct you know one
point in the registered brain and look
at where that would correlate